or at least come that debt and start
saving with the money game money a
financial talk with an attitude do not
despise small beginnings live from the
headquarters of grams and solutions it's
the Dave Ramsey show that's why for the
$3.00 check it mounts once you set it
back through it it bounced twice cos
scored five four three dollar checks you
can avoid cash you're always going to
have payments on thanks is why well
surrender grow get a job and live on
less than you may normal in America is
broke and stupid you don't want to be
normal
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show how can
I help today I have over a hundred
thousand dollars in credit card debt
smiling is too hard to fly I don't know
how to get out of it we going to the
rest of your life
I don't know I'm scared hunter
encouraged but not in its effort I'm
working for hours I'm cutting back our
bills that are unnecessary I have a goal
it is unbelievable when it finally
happens I'm kind of love you well kiddo
while you're here on the air with me I
love you so much
and I want and the rest of my life with
me yes marriages impacted people's
family trees changed so how much have
you paid off 76102 hundred forty
thousand
what's your a debt-free scream
[Applause]
this is what we do here this is how we
do it we do the impossible we go into
the marketplace and do things that no
one else does there are people out there
that God says needs are you can win in
America today change your life change
your destiny change your family tree
you've got this